so here's the plan for the end of the
year sometimes people get mad when we
disappear and don't announce that we
will be off so I'm being super upfront
with you we will be off for the week
between Christmas and New Year's period
I don't know what else to say a lot of
people will be off that week the timing
of the weekends and such make it so that
we're really only missing I think it's
four shows four or five non holiday or
four or four not holidays yeah yeah so
we'll be off and we'll be back January
2nd 2018 we have a lot of great stuff
planned on YouTube will have unreleased
content going out during that last week
we'll have classic episodes on the
podcast feed a lot of extra content in
the works and I do want to take this
opportunity to mention that we do have
an upcoming mini-series on critical
thinking and this is tied to a patreon
fundraising goal you'll you'll notice
that on patreon we have a target of 2250
patrons at which point we will create
and release this 12 to 15 part
miniseries on critical thinking I'm
hoping that that's early in 2018 because
that's a really really exciting project
we also have this wow I just slammed it
I hope that wasn't loud we have the 2018
david pakman show calendar available and
this calendar is a calendar with all 365
days of 2018 that's one of the benefits
of it there are no days missing for the
dorian calendar all the holidays on
there everything all holidays every day
of 2018 January 1 to December 31st is on
this calendar the calendar is made up of
100% original david pakman show audience
created artwork there's one storyline
where I grow a huge beard which is very
funny it's comic strips
it is also art from Korey top kissed
which is available there including this
sort of I guess I call it like an Andy
Warhol Askia image which was a mosaic of
sorts and it originally created by Corey
topic is modified and expanded by
Anthony Pat Ramallah who has been
helping us with the calendar now for
four years running so you can get them
on our web site two options both are at
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 if
you want just the calendar you can get
that either autographed or not
autographed at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 if you want to get the
calendar for free you can do that with a
new yearly member
at david pakman.com slash calendar 18
patsies me he looks over during the day
while he's preparing for the show and
i'm feverishly fervently or fever Antley
as was previously coined by producer
louis addressing and autographing these
things and i walk out with huge stacks
of envelopes and stand at the post
office
everyone's furious because of the amount
of time it get it takes to get all of
these set up for international shipping
we use stamps calm here right packed to
stamp the domestic ones but the
international you need a customs form
people hate me at the post you just have
to look straight ahead at the post
office to you can't look at the line
behind you the line grows to like twenty
people and i just look straight ahead
and not i stay as still as possible to
try to blend in so maybe nobody even
knows I'm there I try to kind of
camouflage myself but anyway I will do
it as long as I need to because we want
to send out as many of these as possible
david pakman.com slash calendar 18